foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Shelburne ESPN NBA Insider senior writer
I know you were going to come on and
talk about the Phoenix Suns situation
let me ask you about what's going on
with Boston Celtics here a possible
year-long suspension this came out of
nowhere Ramona yeah it's been it's been
uh behind the scenes and and we've you
know last night it it came out and it
was I I'm kind of tempering my reaction
until we get all the details here but
um it you know it's obviously
really sad I mean this is one of the
great young coaches in our in the NBA
and took the Boston Celtics to the NBA
finals last year so
um from what I understand about this Dan
it is a really serious situation we
wouldn't be having this discussion and
they wouldn't be having these
discussions if it wasn't
um but and whenever whenever something
is as uh in this situation I think we
need to reserve our judgment on all this
until everything comes out and turn all
the facts come out and and on this one
I'm not sure how many how much all the
facts will come out I think there'll be
some but
um you know this is being held very
close to the vest and it has been for a
little while there in Boston yeah
finally come out I'm just trying to
understand what would warrant a seasoned
long suspension if he said it was a
consensual relationship but
[Music]
um
well in the workplace you know you have
power dynamics right I mean there's
um oh I understand being disciplined
because of that that he's somebody's
superior but yeah for a year right same
for me that's that when I when I first
heard about this that was that was my
thought too it's like that felt very
severe felt very now we had a similar
um situation in Minnesota a couple years
ago with Gerson Road sauce who is the
president of basketball operations who
uh had a consensual relationship with a
team employee and uh both Rosas and the
team employee ended up leaving the
organization and it was sort of over of
their own volition but it was it was
against team policy and against
organizational rules and so
we found out some of the details but but
again there was there was a because both
of them stepped away you only you only
got some of the story and I I'm
wondering how this is going to play out
as it in the next couple of days but
it's it's a it's a messy dicey situation
and um obviously very serious
um to Warrant a year-long suspension I
mean there's you know that's that's an
that's a long punishment for
um for a bright young coach in who had
just had so much success last year if I
told you a week ago Robert Sarver will
be selling the Phoenix Suns Phoenix
Mercury
what would your reaction have been
I would have
I would have given you a nice nod I I
don't think I I don't think I expected
him to sell this quickly I thought he
would eventually sell
um the whole time because I even whether
it was going to happen now or six months
from now or closer to when that
year-long suspension was going to be up
I just didn't see a path for him to uh
continue owning and operating an NBA
franchise after what was in that report
if you really sat down and read the 43
Pages which Chris Paul did which Devin
Booker did DeAndre ayton all the all the
star players in that in that
organization people actually read the
report which I think is why there's been
so much of a somewhat of a delayed
reaction to it so when I covered the
Donald Sterling
um situation in 2014 one of the issues
was you know it was tape we all heard
the tape and you have this very gut
level visceral reaction to a tape and
everybody hears the same thing this is
different in that a lot of the reporting
um is off the record or a source to
return there's not names on these
situations there's no tape for you to
listen to and you actually have to read
43 pages of report some of which
um the details are not all they don't go
all the way with the details because
they're protecting the people whose
stories they are
um they're protecting their identities
and so there was a delayed reaction on
this of of the outcry and the outrage in
the time that it took for people to read
a report and I remember thinking to
myself like that's interesting you know
at this in age like how often do you
read a full book how often do people
read more than what they see in a tweet
or a short article
um I actually give people a lot of
credit for for sitting down and and
going through that report and digesting
it in that in that time frame
it feels like there was pressure applied
somewhere I don't know who applied the
pressure
so the pressure was applied uh publicly
by the players you heard you heard what
Steph Curry it was you sorry you heard
what Chris Paul said wouldn't LeBron
James tweeted what Draymond Green said
um but it was also applied privately
um
you know behind the scenes there was a
there was a lot said and done by Adam
um with with Robert zarber and then
frankly the sponsors you know PayPal is
the only sponsor that came forward
publicly to to denounce what happened
with uh Robert cyber saying they did an
association with the sons afterwards but
there were from what I understand a lot
of sponsors that were joining the line
and The Dominoes were gonna start
falling pretty soon and I think
yesterday in Robert announcing he was
going to sell the team was probably
about the last time he would have been
able to make that announcement or
decision really of his own volition on
his own time frame because the walls
were going to start closing in
yeah I thought that when the
commissioner said hey I can't do
anything
can he start the process of asking the
other owners or Governors about that's
what I wanted hey I can't take away his
team but I you know Roger Goodell did
this but hey I can't take away Daniel's
not well can you start the process and I
wondered if the you know if Adam Silver
was going to start the process with the
other owners
um I think that was on the table I don't
think that had started Dan I don't think
that process but there's one pretty big
difference in that in the NFL when the
report came out on the commanders and
and Dan cider and all that
um that report wasn't released in full
it wasn't really they weren't given a
lot of details
um it the the NBA report is not the full
report of course there was 320 Witnesses
who were interviewed it was distilled
down into 43 pages but there were still
43 pages
um and they were pretty specific on on
certain incidents and um and I thought
uh there was in a way that was the
process right that that is starting the
process like you you drop that into the
water
um and give people time to read it and
digest it and I think the longer that
was in the public uh Consciousness the
more people read it the more
um and I have to give a lot of credit to
the players who who talked about it
publicly because they did it before they
were asked right LeBron James wasn't
asked to his opinion he just gave it on
Twitter and neither was Chris Paul but
they were specific and they were public
in what they called for and I just don't
there wasn't going to be a path for
Robert Sarver to keep owning the team he
was going to fight he fought real hard
behind the scenes
um to keep owning the team but once once
the sponsors started pulling out and
we're about to start pulling out in Mass
that's when I think things really
um change for him and for the league and
they ended up in a place where and let's
be real about it if you're the other
owners in the NBA
um you know in Congress when they vote
on something it's all public right it's
on C-Span and you see who votes on
everything and you have a record in the
NBA those votes are supposed to be
private but you and I both know that
every vote would Elite we would have
found out who voted for what and um you
know there's a if if they had voted for
Roberts I would stay in the league you'd
have to answer that if you voted against
Robert Sarver you'd have to answer that
it was a it was vote no one really
wanted to take or make and I think and
this is how these things usually go
Robert Sarver became very bad for
business right
um yeah for the NBA business and for the
sun's business and um
that's why we saw him voluntarily decide
to sell now he's going to do a lot of
business on this sale again
bought the team for about 400 million
and he's gonna I I think he'll get my my
just in my conversation I think it'll go
for above three billion dollars three
billion
a lot of money wow I mean so there's a
there's a there's a lot of debate over
that right now but we have a few
guidelines which is there was a they
were valued um when there was a dial
Capital which is a hedge fund invested
in them last summer and uh in 2021 and
it was a 1.55 billion valuation for a
minority share okay so that's not
control
this would be buying the team with full
control and so that's worth a lot more
than 1.55 that was also a year ago and
now we're coming up on a new CBA new TV
rights deal the NBA is a whole lot more
valuable
um than it was even a year ago it's
recovered from the pandemic
um all the viewership and rights are up
I think this could be an incredible
number would be potentially goes through
potential owners uh seems like you've
got some guys who certainly have the
money yeah uh what are you hearing
yeah I mean look it's still really early
and and the important thing to remember
here is Sarver has control of the sale I
mean when when Shelly Sterling sold the
Clippers she got to decide she she said
I want to sell it to one guy I want to
sell it to a group
um wait the league doesn't have any say
in this yeah they'll say he'll approved
you know they'll approve at the at the
end but it's his team it's his franchise
he gets to decide it's like if I sell my
house I get to choose the buyer right
um and so there is some influence
they'll get to have but he still has
quite a bit of Leverage here
um and you know that's important because
when we look at uh potential owners from
within like let's say the minority
Partners uh people who own smaller
stakes in the Suns now
um you know would he sell to one of his
uh co-owners now or is it going to come
from the outside my understanding it's
like most likely going to come from the
outside
um and you made the relationship with
cyber might matter here generally
speaking when it comes down to it high
is better wins right but um there's a
lot of there's going to be a lot of
interest here I've already heard names
like Jeff Bezos
um Bob Iger who used to run Disney uh
you know Lorraine jobs the the you know
Larry Ellison these are these are names
that have been out there
um the state of Sheldon Adelson
um those are those are there's a lot of
interest in this and plus you know I
think somebody told me yesterday I
always always think about who will own
minority shares in NBA teams right now
because a lot of times owners it's like
you you join an ownership group in one
city and then a couple years later later
you get you know enough money you can
put a group together yourself and so
those are a lot of candidates we haven't
even thought about yet but there'll be a
lot of interest in Sons because it's a
great Market Phoenix you know you go to
Scottsdale all the time right
um great Market great team
um and it's a good time for the NBA with
the TV rights deal and the new CBA
coming up
thanks for joining us Ramona we
appreciate it thanks Dan that's Ramona
Shelburne ESPN NBA Insider senior writer
there a lot of good information there